.
HERE WITH MORE LARA TRUMP AND
RADIO HOST DANA.
LARA TRUMP, WHAT IF YOUR
FATHER-IN-LAW WERE PRESIDENT AND
ABANDONED AMERICANS BEHIND ENEMY
LINES AND HAD TO BEG OPEC FOR
OIL AND FIRE AMERICAN OIL
WORKERS.
KILL CHILDREN IN A DRONE STRIKE
AND SAY I UNDERSTAND PAIN TOO.
OPEN BORDERS IN THE MIDDLE OF
A PANDEMIC.
INFLATION AND I AM JUST TOUCHING
THE SURFACE HERE.
THERE WOULD BE A VERY DIFFERENT
REACTION IN THE MEDIA AND
ELSEWHERE.
THOUGHTS?
>> YES.
IT'S HYPOCRISY.
WE KNOW.
WE HAVE SEEN IT FIRSTHAND
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF MY
FATHER-IN-LAW'S ADMINISTRATION
AND NOW COMPAREING TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
IT HASN'T BEEN ENOUGH.
THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS FOR
JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS WAS
KILLING THE EXCEL PIPELINE AND
PUTTING THOUSANDS OF ENERGY
WORKERS OUT OF A JOB.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH THEY ARE PAYING
PEOPLE TO STAY HOME FROM WORK.
SMALL BUSINESSES CAN'T RUN
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T FIND WORKERS
TO WORK AFTER THE PANDEMIC.
THIS IS WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
13 DEAD INDIVIDUALS AND WE HAVE
BEEN GIVING U.S. MILITARY
EQUIPMENT, NOW 83 BILLION
DOLLARS OF IT TO TERRORISTS
ORGANIZATIONS.
NOW WE HAVE AN OPEN BORDER AND
PAYING ON THE TAXPAYER DIMES TO
SEND THEM ACROSS THE COUNTRY ON
THE PLANES AND THE BUSES.
AMERICA, JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA
HARRIS AND THE DEMOCRATS DO NOT
CARE ABOUT YOU.
THEY DO NOT CARE ABOUT
SQUANDERING YOUR TAXPAYER MONEY.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT YOUR
LIVELIHOOD.
THEY DO NOT CARE ABOUT YOUR
CONSTITUTION RIGHTS AND CIVIL
RIGHTS.
THEY CARE ABOUT THEMSELVES AND
REMAINING IN POWER.
THE MEDIA HAS BEEN COVERING UP
FOR THEM.
NOW AMERICANS ARE OUT RAGED.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR 2022 AND 2024.
>> Sean: I DON'T LIKE BEING LIED
TO AND MAYORKAS LIED TO US.
ONLY 90 SECONDS BUT HONE IN ON
THAT.
>> MAYORKAS LIED TO US.
HE NEEDS TO STEP DOWN.
SEAN, LARA TRUMP, I MISS YOUR
FATHER-IN-LAW AND THE DAILY
PRESS CONFERENCES.
THE BIDEN/HARRIS ADMINISTRATION
COULD SEND PLANES FOR PEOPLE
CROSSING THE BORDER ILLEGALLY
AND COULD NOT SEND THEM FOR
PEOPLE IN KABUL BUT FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE ILLEGALLY ENTERING AT
THE BORDER.
THAT'S WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITY IS.
THE BORDER IS OPEN.
IF THEY CAN PICK AND CHOOSE THE
FEDERAL LAWS THEY WILL FOLLOW
THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS CAN PICK
AND CHOOSE WHAT FEDERAL LAWS HE
WILL FOLLOW.
WE HAVE HAD ENOUGH.
>> Sean: WELL SAID.
WE ARE ONLY